hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play train now I'm
very excited about this one because a
lot of people were spamming my emails
and it's so hard to get a good horror
game these days I mean most of what you
see is um very heavy into the indie
scene very early development stuffin and
kind of repetitious on previous
experiences so I'm very excited to be
playing this one if it's good you know
if it is I haven't seen much about it I
haven't seen gameplay videos of it all
I've heard is that everyone is
suggesting it to me that it is good so
I'm gonna trust them on this one and
move forward
alright looks fantastic it's made on the
Unity engine if you weren't if you
didn't know that already and I believe
the developers are Russian or some other
country in that area I'm not exactly
sure okay hang on stay an ETU stuff and
this train is moving yes indeed I have
deduced with my amazing investigational
skills that this train is indeed moving
alright yeah I gotta say it's really
hard to get well-developed in the [ __ ]
games especially you know now I mean
there's a lot of stuff that's on the
horizon but for right now the scene is
pretty much tapped out so I really do
appreciate the effort they put into this
what is that what is that is that a
little girl pointing up there excuse me
little girl
okay you got snazzy music empty bottles
of booze someone's been drinking
I don't know why that silhouette of that
girl is pointing up there but let's just
keep moving forward nothing to worry
about just some normal train turbulence
rough buffets of air on the ground doors
are blocked by a chain I can't broke it
if I find something
yeah I can't block it you find something
then I would be able to okay let me see
if that little silhouette of the girl is
pointing up to like like a panel maybe I
don't know little girl what you doing
I'm not crazy that's a little girl with
pigtails isn't it I got to find
something so can't jump I'm just gonna
assume that there's a pair of bolt
cutters around here somewhere it can
only get through the chain I'm just
spamming the use button as I wander
through the dark corridor as I stump
through the train I feel a sense of
unease as I realize that there's
absolutely no one else on this train
which is kind of weird but oh well I
guess everyone else in this town is dead
are we on the train to Silent Hill that
what we're doing right now is there
another like hello oh no there has to be
some I can't be stuck this early I can't
be that stupid I know the comments
section is blowing up right now after I
said that like yes you can be that
stupid we believe in you markiplier we
know you can be that stupid
thank you for your unending support my
loyal fans
seems like I'm gonna be ah here we go
okay bout it
whoa what is that is that a lockpick
okay got something thief
Lok ping I can use it good for you
I guess that's saying that he has the
knowledge to use it as opposed to the
will oh I didn't even notice the bad
luck
boom got it alright moving forward much
bright oh it's so beautiful we in
Siberia it's gorgeous I like it
the mood is definitely chinta say what
what all this stuff was at there was a
tree but all this stuff come from
hello hi jingle jingle didn't expect
that tax lien cool alright then
Oh flashback time oh oh okay then I'm
back home more empty bottles of booze
can I get out can I go away that would
be awfully nice nope
okay oh excuse me I still have a little
of a cough oh what a handsome family
handsome wholesome family can I go in
there no I don't see anything in there
I'm hoping that there's nothing gonna
pop out
oh look is that mine am ia little kid is
that my trikey Dingle Dingle
your note on the desk childs happy is a
parts of a few surprises ice cream in
the hot summer day a present under
Christmas tree in new year but nothing
of this can substitute mother and
father's love okay so I'm mi the kid I
might be the kid I'm not sure okay
[Music]
all right enough of that that's
nightmare fuel there ever was any
freaky figured you're this strange
Mickey Mouse aren't you
so can I open this door or what oh oh
back on the train is this a train right
before a big nuke goes off oh hello what
go surprise me
I picked up the ball and I apparently I
have sick I have five fingers in a thumb
Oh what I can close my eyes why can't
why why am I gonna need to close my eyes
why in the hell would I ever need to
close my eyes that's what I want to know
it now that's what I want to know right
now
oh hello horsey what the endo I didn't
even say that it's a ghost it's a good
good good good good go I closed my eyes
will you
hi oh you're creaking too much for being
a little horsey
hi hi little girl little boy I don't
know are you the girl with pigtails you
sound like it
okay shouldn't it touched her oh man
that is creepy
okay touching was a bad idea I died I
think okay I wait hang on I'm gonna go
get the ball I must throw it at it how
about that little toy a little girly you
want your ball Oh little baby little
ghosty baby crying away what a ball do
you wanna bully doing you little bully
Wow oh wait now hang on I'm gonna give
you this you can go away right there you
go sorry about the oh hey I did wha
I didn't even notice that on the ground
I was just too much of a genius to
anticipate you're welcome little girl I
seriously I did not notice that on the
ground that was totally my gamer
intuition being super awesome proneness
levels I am just too amazing to stop
this you're gonna okay I see that this
kinda reminds me of no you stay away you
see you son of a [ __ ] okay I'm just
gonna keep walking should to stay away
from them well how I can barely see them
how do i oh that's how I can use okay
all right go to hell whatever I don't
care it's fine
better lock the doors from with
something from inside like why I'm so
glad that there are clues everywhere
helping me couldn't do anything you
can't leave me I couldn't do anything
man this game is brutal and unforgiving
better lock the doors with something
inside how how do I do that how do I do
that I don't see anything that can be
used there's got to be some right gotta
be some balsa booze sody pop better lock
the doors
I can't even close the doors what am I
supposed to do I don't know what I'm
supposed to do I can't see anything I
don't have a flashlight I I'm at a total
loss cuz if I go forward I will die
a horrible horrible death will befall me
[Music]
I got no idea
maybe there's something oh that looked
like us something ah now kill me don't
take me into the light I was so close
okay I see a stick and there was an axe
over there
can I get that can I there's an friggin
axe come on you say I can't use those
get away from me stupid little kids it's
all that love the damn door I see the
thingies
maybe yeah maybe I got trigger though I
better look the door with them then I
get a good good no no I'm at a loss
don't ask me stupid toaster but figure
this out bye little kitties thanks for
being sons of [ __ ] oh wait a minute
oh you gotta be joking me I could go in
ah
that's frickin bull oh I thought if I
walked out oh come on that was not my
fault guys I was misled to believe that
if I walked in I would be dead so I got
to find something to block it up from in
here so what could I use just Max's over
here I'm in this drawer a book about the
guitar this book on the paranormal
someone is lucky to born strong proud
Falcon and eat the fresh meat and
someone will born in hole and eat
carrion okay that's weird
yang can I pick that up or am I just
gonna keep stringing it
a week hang on what what is this is this
what I'm supposed to use to block up the
door really this book this book how
about it how about it let's do it let's
do it if I just drop this book right
here you guys won't bother me no more
right
oh there's a key well where did that
come from
mother humper god damn okay I got the
key all right let's do this
perfect let's do it lock the door which
door do i lock with my key what do I do
I've been wandering around for what I
got a key I know I picked it up lock the
damn doors just lock them lock them good
in the neighborhood lock the Frick damn
dingdong doors alright whatever you know
what maybe I'm good
maybe I'm good and I can just move on
maybe yeah come on
oh they're all there we go I spam at ten
bajillion times flashback time time to
go into Willy Wonka's okay what all
right then I can't understand you
Oh someone's getting in there maybe this
wasn't such a handsome wholesome family
oh I put the picture straight and I can
go through here I still gotta say
graphics are looking pretty dang good in
this one I like the atmosphere
save yeah I saved oh hello wait a minute
wait a minute hang on a second are you
really real okay anyway so it said it
saved maybe it did maybe it did not but
we will find out later so anyway thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
[Music]